ah the first day of December I'm so
excited I decided to announce that date
to myself run right what what's going on
there's no time to explain
I only did it let my love a Christmas
destroy the world
the state will come and I got a review
to do it's Christmas the greatest time
of the year is back Santa snowflakes -
apocalyptic flames Prisma says
everything anyone could want and that
includes Christmas specials every year
dozens of new Christmas specials trying
to get made in the hopes of becoming a
staple of the legendary Howard but the
special we're going to talk about today
is a staple for a different reason one
that you have to say by god we actually
did that and that of course is the
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtle Christmas
also known as we wish you a turtle
Christmas this came out just at the time
the turtles were doing the rock and roll
- yep
because rapping with Vanilla Ice wasn't
embarrassing enough they decided to
bring their music to the world because
nobody demanded it hell they even made
an appearance on Oprah to promote the
tour just look at how excited those kids
are her into an interspecies
relationships for months now I think
this kid's face sums it all up
as you can see it wasn't enough that
they've ruined rock music they found it
necessary to ruin the holidays as well
the short isn't even that long ringing
in at a measly 22 minutes but trust me
when I say you feel every one of those
22 this short is so bad even Michael Bay
took a crack at gonna finish her a hip
hop Christmas album bro yeah when
Michael Bay is calling you a desperate
sellout you know it's gotta be bad it's
a tough one to watch whether you're a
Turtles fan or not so sit back and enjoy
as it might be the last thing you ever
sit back and enjoy this is we wish you a
turtle Christmas so in the review active
sewers of New York so neon yellow that
even the taxi tires can't block him out
the turtles are singing about the fact
that their Turtles it's pretty much all
the band every song about
I love that they keep cutting back to
footage of real turtles as if the
costumes are so bad that they had to
show you what they're supposed to be
representing but can you blame them they
look like melting terminus frog bars
with bizarrely good dental work oddly
enough even though it's a musical
special it goes deathly quiet when the
credits pop up as if a moment of silence
is needed for the production that's
about to die right in front of you the
director of this by the way is Larry
Osbourne if that name rings a bell it's
because his brother Barry Osbourne perdu
some of the most popular films in recent
years how do I know this because it's
literally the only thing on Larry's IMDB
page that he did this and his brother is
Barry Osborne there's actually more
about Barry on his page than him would
you love to be a fly on the wall at that
family reunion so brother what do you
been up to well I'm living off the
residuals of the lore the Rings and
Matrix movies how about you turtle
Christmas do I even need to say anything
though you don't so we get our first
musical number if you can call it that
I'm not gonna call it that as the
creators of this for a brief moment
so does Leo think he is in fact the tree
just kind of puts lights on himself and
never really takes them off I'll admit
you're about as lifeless as a tree but
with you in its place instead of giving
kids dreams of sugarplums they'll most
likely be dreaming that face of death
from The Exorcist bebop Rocksteady like
God for that Camacho what say what looks
like let's all sing this
did he just say sing this part together
let's all sing this man even they're not
hiding gonna turn there and record skip
what do we do go with it so after that
Yuletide slaughtering of a classic they
realized they might have forgotten to
get a gift for their Master Splinter's
wait a minute are you guys telling me
that nobody got a gift for splinter I
don't believe you guys
well at least tell me you got better
adapters for the wires bulging out of
our necks or the backpack straps they're
supposed to be our shells you know what
never turn around did mal we have to get
a gift for splinter so while walking
through the phenomenally lit sewers of
New York and after Mikey puts on his
airplane scarf uly4 his air battle with
Snoopy the turtle sing a song about
getting a gift for splinter God's sakes
close your mouths how much does it cost
just to have those things close their
mouths you're making the Garbage Pail
Kids look adorable though to be closing
it really
I don't
well that's a new one
Michelangelo's teeth move but somehow
his lips remained completely still you
know watching the turtles costumes
digress with every continuing project is
kind of like watching the effects of
alcohol abuse
we then come across I am assuming
homeless kids who love to play
instruments that apparently make no
sound I don't think that upside-down
bucket is plugged in kid really be used
to life on the streets as apparently
half-burnt chucky cheese animatronics
don't seem to face them in the least
just push that kid out of the song see
once you get the hell out of your Billie
you're not stealing off Thunder yeah
consider yourself lucky
next time we'll feed you to my keys
sagging vagina right no crackers show
less teeth than they do
yeah just don't look him in the face
Tommy we steal your souls we should just
kidnap these random kids I'm assuming
splinter is pro-slavery it would be the
first time you kidnapped him brainwash
people I just like to point out to you
guys that they're only two hours of
shopping left before Christmas they then
stopped in front of a Christmas tree
where Mikey decides to sing opera I
don't think there's a mania for how
stupid this is what the hell do Ninja
Turtles an opera have in common
it's like Dorothy Gale suddenly singing
metal I say it's like Dorothy Gale
suddenly singing metal hello sorry it
took so long my eyesight just adjusted
from that explosion well you obviously
don't have the Christmas spirit like I
do now where's your Dorothy costume I
used it to mend my wounds Oh whatever
just do the voice exit light enter night
I didn't know any better I'd say someone
was a ha me humbug bite my ass you dick
twit just for that you get to be my new
footstool so you would think
Michelangelo singing opera while wearing
a Red Baron scarf would be strange
enough but believe it or not the scene
gets even stranger first of all why does
there one solitary snow cloud hovering
over them there's clearly no snow in the
background maybe God feels he can shut
down production by having it storm in
one place fingers crossed
also nobody seems to acknowledge this
this is clearly a New York moment as
none of these people not even Santa
Claus give a shit that there's 4 Turtles
singing under a soapy suds dispenser
just look at Santa's reaction here
oh okay thanks for that I'll continue
helping the less fortunate while you
creepily sing in front of trees oh
there's a Jack and Coke waiting for me
tonight get a load of this scene they
act like they're gonna pick him up yeah
never mind we have a filming permit for
like five minutes we'll just grab that
scene Donnie you okay there you look
like you suddenly got hypnotized by
Mikey's amazing ass
by jesus's mercy it stops as Raph
reveals that there's a little time left
hey guys one shopping laughs man a
moment ago you said was two hours
we somehow wasted an hour on this one
song
maybe the specials not operating on how
long it really is but instead how long
it feels that's what she said
you
so the turtles finally get splinter a
whole bunch of gifts after practicing
their ventriloquist of course deep these
dude I'm going to cover I'm undercover
too I'm a puppeteer killing his dreams
and thus it's time to rap and I bet
you'll never guess what style of music
they use to do that you guessed it
country-western of course naturally
because the seething rhythms and the
zen-like process no of course nice
frigging rap that's right you are the
first ones to ever make this pun I also
thought of a joke where someone says
they're not gonna do something and I'm
doing it but well the only thing as good
as the koi ography in this number is the
incredible camera I 19 kidding this is
all it does throughout the entire
portion you think this was intentional
with the operator just trying to put
them in focus and I can't find any angle
that makes them look good so when we go
start filming we were man it's a turtle
Christmas who gives a shit
fun fact this is actually the music they
play when they welcome you to hell it's
a good choice and the visual of the
turtles definitely reinforces a
welcoming to your nightmares motif have
to fill up that monstrous 22 minute
running times somehow they wake up
Christmas morning and open their gifts
with splinter who we see for the first
time in this special and how do I
describe in um you've got a gerbil crawl
into a bathroom sink and die and then
you had to scoop him up and not show the
kids because he's just too horrendous to
look at that plus the voice of the Trade
Federation guys from Phantom Menace
to me truly a match made in heaven
who the hell's the girl my god
maybe they did kidnap those kids for
splinter she definitely doesn't look
happy to be down there to child slaves
you see that little girl that's gonna be
your dinner for eight weeks we laminated
it after we left it out for about a
month
again I feel like this specials concept
of time is a bit of skewed they are
clearly no day's passing and the singing
of this on though looking at them
they're probably so high that they think
days are going by like seconds remember
that incredible 22 minute running time
they're trying their damnedest to fill
well that probably answers your next
disappointing question yes they sing the
entire 12 days of Christmas because the
specials already made itself so easy to
like you know I don't usually say this
but if you haven't offed yourself at
some point while watching this you're
probably not well it's not rare that I
say that if you haven't thought about
death then I'd be concerned about your
mental health
I guess the special is just that
powerful my favorite is that the purpose
belief love a line as if to say yeah
even we caught on that you don't give a
shit so why the hell should we well
Antonio other dress
fine video games made it oh I doubt
anybody in this special made it I am
grateful to you for the many gifts you
have given me it is a time of sharing
and thinking of those less fortunate
than you like the audience remember my
sons that your love for me is the
greatest gift you could bestow or in our
case a slave where are they getting all
these kids did one of the turtles get
April knocked up and they just have them
for the weekend and this weird mullet
kid who nobody knows and don't forget NC
er Cole pants clearly staying in style
for years
and public domain songs we can steal
with ease the mic was too early ask you
there
we'll just edited out impose no Who am I
kidding nobody's gonna edit this feel
really bad for this one girl because it
looks like she's actually trying she
legitimately looks enthusiastic and
joyful during this terrifying circus of
Horrors I just want to grab her and say
kid it's not worth it
you won't even put this on your resume
if you know what's good for you you look
happy but we know it's a lot just don't
give the effort no one else is and I
know it sounds even stranger compared to
all the strangeness we've seen but one
of the most interesting things is the
end credits just look at all these
people who worked on this if you truly
want to do something helpful for
Christmas you'll pay for every one of
their therapy bills this couldn't have
left a good mark on it I'll put some
quotes around that credit i kind of
doubt anybody really performed in this
and just when you think you're free to
escape this culture and of
disappointment you find there's still 30
seconds left in the special so they just
keep going how about some of my
favorites like girl rat breath was that
something awesome or what man hey that
was some Christmas tree though wasn't it
oh man it was like totally awesome oh my
god was this in their contract you have
to have exactly 22 minutes even if our
budget shows nothing but a blank screen
it's not even funny what they're saying
it's just uncomfortable oh come on man
I'm trying to do the best I can
it was like you know last second
shopping come on Leah it sounds like
they're having a legitimately hostile
family moment yeah we're trying to go
out and buy a sneaker with two toes the
Lydia almost like left me out of Macy's
man it's going on out there no it was
with that pair of sneakers you got me
they were a little too small for my feet
and I only have three toes thank you
very you know why do I even have family
over why don't I just go and talk oh
yeah who miss yeah
and that was we wish you a turtle
Christmas I know it might sound kind of
insane but are you actually kind of
recommend it
really it's so horrible so cheap and so
ridiculous
it kind of it has to be seen to be
believed it's hilarious how half-assed a
desperate it is which in all honesty
makes for some really fun entertainment
it's just so crazy to see the end of a
popular franchise do everything in its
power to try and stay cool and fail on
every single front it's not good at all
by any means but it is to be fair very
entertaining if you're a glutton for
some damn funny punishment this is a
horrendously enjoyable giggle to pity
I'll take a lot more than special like
this to ruin Christmas oh you mean like
a jackass who blew up the entire world
okay I might have let the excitement go
a little to my head but why can't you be
dancing for joy like now come over
because he's a zombie what other there I
don't know all apocalypses of zombies
now let's not worry about that let's
instead wish the good people at home a
Merry Christmas the world is in flames I
will make a cannon now why don't you get
over there and give Malcolm a great big
Christmas attic merry Christmas to you
all I hope you have a wonderful rest of
the year love and compassion for the
people
hey everybody I don't usually make an
appearance just before the end credits
like this but I just want to remind you
as we send the last video that the
IndieGoGo campaign for the Dragon's Lair
movie with Don Bluth returning to
hand-drawn animation begins today and
for a second I want you to forget about
Don Bluth I want you to forget about his
incredible animation as wonderful movies
and stuff and I instead want you to
think about moments the moments that you
grew up with and stuck with you for such
a long time
chances are several of them if not many
of them came from Don Bluth think about
when fifl was reunited with his family
or when Littlefoot is sharing his last
moments with his mother or when charlie
is saying goodbye to Anne Marie knowing
that they're both going to be in better
places soon every Christmas I watch a
short he did call the small one and it
is I've now realized a perfect short
everything is done to perfection every
emotion you're supposed to feel you feel
these are moments that still stay with
us from childhood and it didn't say
everything's bright everything's
colorful everything's happy it took you
to some really scary dark places it
didn't shy away from this really really
tough stuff but it was earned because
there was always that glimmer of hope
there was always that beautiful
something at the end that made all those
tough moments worth it so I want you to
consider not only this as a chance to
get this master of animation back to his
craft and to see this movie back quite
frankly a lot of us have always wanted
to see we've always said there should be
a movie but I want you to see it very
much as a way of saying thank you thanks
for giving these unbelievable moments if
all the people that watch me gave a
couple bucks we can make this goal very
easily and let's say that you're not
into animation and you never really got
into these movies or something good fair
enough you know you don't have to
support something you don't believe in
but I got a feeling I'm not alone on
this that a lot of other
people were really moved and really
touched by the hard work and the effort
that he put into these incredible
moments show your support but most of
all your appreciation to someone that
has proven himself as a true artist and
has given us so many beautiful wonderful
moments I'm the Nostalgia Critic let's
all remember
you
let's all sing this part together